White House Budget Director Mick
Mulvaney joins us from Washington good
morning director good morning and thanks
for having me let me ask you when all is
said and done will the Republican health
care plan cover more Americans or less
Americans than Obamacare we really think
it will cover more keep in mind it's
easy to claim success under Obamacare
when you had a government mandate
because you could sort of say well
everybody's covered but is that really
the question the question is not if you
get sick you don't really care if you
have insurance you care whether or not
you can get health care and that's what
we think Obamacare came up so short it
was created a system where it was
affordable to buy insurance but not
affordable to actually go to the doctor
and we think the system that the house
introduced last night that we worked
with very closely with the house and
support actually provides more
affordable health care for people so
when they do get sick they can afford to
go to the doctor I know that you were
hoping to do and across-the-board tax
credit for everyone but the new plan
phases the credits out for individuals
making 75 thousand dollars a year or
families making a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year why the change
we just had input from a bunch of
different folks and some people were
uncomfortable as we started the
negotiations with allowing folks who are
making more than that to sort of get
this tax credit what was it designed to
do by the way it's it's only designed to
cover people or to assist people who
don't get coverage at work director one
of the key changes here is that you're
eliminating the government's mandate
that you must have health insurance and
replacing it with a penalty for a lapse
encouraged and again coverage and
increase in premiums how exactly is that
going to work it's called continuous
coverage and it's sort of how we've
proposed to deal with this concept
called adverse selection one of the
problems with Obamacare now is that you
can wait to buy insurance until after
you get sick what we try and do is give
people an incentive to go off and say
look if you're really worried about that
go up and sign up now and make sure that
you can prove that you had continuous
coverage and then if you do get sick you
can't lose your coverage but if you if
you have a penalty kicking in if your
insurance lapse won't that ultimately
discourage people from getting back into
the insurance market no I think the
exact opposite it would encourage people
especially young healthy people one of
the groups
Obamacare was never able to get into the
system it's one of the reason that
Obamacare was such a dismal economic
failure what can you tell us director
about the cost of this plan because
right now the Congressional Budget
Office hasn't reviewed it right we don't
expect the Congressional Budget Office
to give us any numbers for the next
couple of days but at the office of
management budget a couple other
agencies including HHS we've run our own
numbers and were absolutely convinced
because of the efficiencies that we
drive for example we're giving States
for the first time more control over
their own Medicaid money we'd really do
think it sounds like it's fairly
esoteric down in the weeds those types
of innovations allowing States to have
more control over their Medicaid money
drive tremendous long-term savings
director one of the things that the
Republican plan is does keep coverage
for pre-existing conditions let me ask
you about preventative care one of the
things that Obamacare did was expand
coverage and mandate coverage for
preventive care such as mammograms
contraceptive care also mental health
screenings will that continue under this
Republican plan yeah the way we get at
those things is a dramatic expansion of
health savings accounts so that you can
use your pre-tax dollars we double the
size of them are nearly double the size
of them and then dramatically increase
where you can use them so we do feel
that people will still have the ability
to get that type of care in a very
affordable fashion all right director
Mulvaney thank you for joining us thank
you